pues bien nos tenemos que remontar un
poco hacia la historia recordemos
irlanda está dividida en dos por una
parte esta es la del norte de la región
del ulster que forma parte del reino
unido- y por otra parte en el sur está
la república de irlanda un país soberano
que forma parte de la unión europea y
que es lo que ocurre durante 30 años
hubo un durísimo conflicto en la región
de irlanda del norte porque por una
parte había un grupo de personas que
querían unirse al a la república de
irlanda y otros que querían formar parte
del reino unido después de este durísimo
conflicto en que hubo muchas muertes
muchos atentados y hubo muchos problemas
en la región se decidió que hubiese un
acuerdo el acuerdo de viernes santo a
finales de los 90 concretamente en 1998
en que este acuerdo entre otras
cuestiones diría que no podía haber una
frontera física entre la región de
irlanda del norte y la república de
irlanda esto se podría producir gracias
a que ambos países el reino unido- y
también la república de irlanda en parte
de la unión europea no existen fronteras
físicas desde 1993 porque hay una
libertad de circulación de personas y
mercancías pero con el requisito todo
cambio y aquí empezaron los problemas en
el acuerdo de salida finalmente se
decidió entre bruselas y londres de que
no podría haber esta frontera física que
se así que se decidió que irlanda del
norte formará parte del mercado único y
así no habría estos controles pero
algunas mercancías se que debían tener
controles en para entrar de reino unido
a irlanda y aquí es donde empiezan aquí
los problemas porque el partido del dup
el partido protestante se queja de que
esto podría provocar que es como si
irlanda del norte forma formara parte
del reino unido- por ello el gobierno de
boris johnson ahora pide cambios en este
protocolo de irlanda para que no haya
estos controles y por lo tanto no haya
más conflicto en la región